Barack Obama warns Democrats if they
move too far left to lose but will they
listen Plus Eric's wawel denies it but
did he supply it i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressive VPN stand up for your digital
rights visit expressvpn comm slash Ben
okay so we begin today with the most
important story that's happened in
America since Epstein didn't kill
himself and that of course is the great
question of the day whether congressman
Eric's wawel former presidential
candidate who's whose candidacy didn't
last nearly as long as a fart in the
wind whether he actually blew a large
gas on national TV
lesson I know it's not an important
story I know it's not an important story
but hey if we can't have fun with this
then what can we have fun with it so
that's nice NBC I paired that heart
about Chris Matthews because unless
you'd roll out in a studio setting
Eric's wall about impeachment in the
Middle East talked XY was tech
management I said right my ear something
wild happening X well go uncontradicted
that the president used taxpayer dollars
to ask the Ukrainians to help him cheat
an election okay come on if he can't
laugh at a fart joke what can you laugh
at now MSNBC did claim he denied it he
did
sois well denied it did he supply it I
think the rules speak for themselves you
can see that the fear in his eyes as
this
I'm contradicted that the president used
taxpayer dollars to ask the Ukrainians
to help him cheat an election
hey then there's a mile deposit in any
case I'm a maya fart truther I don't
know
in any case Herricks well well denies
that he did this Chris Matthews also
tonight he said wasn't me I ain't doing
any there I mean come on you think I
don't care I just see downside if it was
me I play hardball here I don't hide the
ball if it was me blowing on national TV
you think I'd hide that not brag about
it I talk about having the best MSNBC's
the best place for gas on national TV
you think I'd do that
Kathleen tell them hardball actually
claimed that it was their mark actually
claim that it was Chris Matthews moving
a mug moving a mug on on his desk and
that is what caused and then they tried
to sell the hardball mug on that basis
and and as Josh barro the columnist said
I'm not sure that a farting mug is
actually your best pitch for people
by the mug huh in any case is any does
any of this matter no but listen guys if
we can't take a break from politics for
just a second and come together around a
man even Alyssa Milano Alyssa Milano and
I disagree on everything but again there
are certain simple joys in life that
bring us back to our childhood and a
solid fart joke on national TV I think
that does it okay in a second we're
gonna get to actual important news but
first let's talk about how you can be
supplied with the greatest stakes on
this planet this season Omaha Steaks is
sharing an amazing limited time offer
with my listeners to get a jump on your
holiday shopping you know what the dudes
in your life are looking for they're
looking for fantastic meets as the
holidays approach so head on over to
Omaha Steaks calm enter the code
Shapiro's in the search bar and order
the favorite gift package the gift
anyone who loves steak will love for
only 69 at 99 order now and you'll get 4
6 ounce bacon-wrapped filet mignons for
premium pork chops for Omaha steak
burgers for perfectly brown potatoes
Augustin for made from scratch caramel
apple tartlets and Omaha Steaks
signature seasoning packet plus only for
my listeners a free six piece cutlery
set and cutting board which is an
awesome gift set I have a lot of friends
may not be even keeping the kosher and
they love these steaks I mean then the
bacon-wrapped filet mignons I have her
bacon is incredible by the way certain
things you know Judaism you take them on
you're like ah man wish I in any case
this is good stuff if somebody sent you
in the mail wouldn't you love it all
this delicious food plus the free
cutlery set they'll enjoy for years to
come for only $69.99 Omaha Steaks is a
fifth-generation family-owned company
over a hundred years of expertise in
delivering perfectly aged beef hand cut
by master butchers in the heartland of
America again order now you get the
favorite gift package plus the free six
piece cutlery set and cutting board only
$69.99 just head on over to Omaha Steaks
com2 Shapiro in the search bar for the
special deal don't wait the offer and
soon order the favorite gift package
today in advance of Thanksgiving and
Christmas it will be awesome everyone
will appreciate it go to Omaha Steaks
calm and type Shapiro in the search bar
and then after you get somebody to get
package then ask them to invite you over
so you can share the meat because come
on
again Omaha Steaks calm typed appear Oh
in the search bar okay so in actual news
the big question for Democrats going
into 2020 is just how radical can they
be and there's something Roman
since actually about 2008 here slightly
okay in 2008 there were serious talk
about whether Barack Obama was too
radical to be the nominee
now Obama really hit it Obama didn't
proclaim that he was quite as radical as
he ended up being in talk nationalized
health care quite as much early on in
the campaign he sort of proposed that he
was a moderate who's gonna unite the
blue states and the red states we're all
gonna get together we're all the same
and then of course he ended up being a
fairly radical left president but there
was some controversy over whether he was
too far to the left because obviously
who's running against Hillary Clinton
who was widely perceived as more
moderate and the Democratic Party said
no we're gonna go with the more radical
guy and then of course Obama ends up
being a sort of once in a generation
candidate and wins a sweeping victory
over John McCain well now Barack Obama
is warning the Democrats that they are
too far left now when Barack Obama is
warning you that you are too far left
okay this is Stalin morning Trotsky that
he is not in line because the fact is
that Barack Obama he's not he's not
Stalin but the point is that Barack
Obama is in fact a far left guy and when
he is warring the Democrats that they
are so far over the rails that Donald
Trump is gonna win reelection you might
think that the Democrats would take a
hint but they're not some far-left
Democrats very angry at Obama they've
been using the hashtag too far left
sniping at Obama Obama told a group of
Democrats owners at a dinner events on
Friday evening quote even as we push the
envelope and we are bold in our vision
we also have to be rooted in reality the
average American doesn't think we have
to completely tear down the system and
remake it and that's obviously him sort
of slapping at Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders he says I don't think we
should be deluded into thinking that the
resistance to certain approaches to
things is simply because voters haven't
heard of bold enough proposal and if
they hear something as bold as possible
then immediately that's going to
activate them when this of course is
true because in the swing states the
fact is that the vast majority of voters
are not in favor of Medicare for all
Elizabeth Warren as for proposals have
been exposed to the light of day has
been dropping in the polls pretty
significantly again the betting odds on
Elizabeth Warren have dropped
dramatically over the past few weeks in
the middle of October she was a better
than 50 percent she's better than 50
percent in the odds to take the
nomination now she's all the way down at
29 percent in the odds with Biden at 24
percent and people to judge at 19
percent and the fact is that
now Elizabeth Warren is only leading in
one state New Hampshire which happens to
be next door to her home state of
Massachusetts IP Buddha judges in the
lead in Iowa Warren is running second
maybe third depending on where you put
Biden in those poll numbers in New
Hampshire Warren is running first Biden
is running second and then in all the
other states Biden is cleaning up so
Elizabeth Warren has been dropping like
a stone from Barack Obama is correct
about all of this and the proof is in
the pudding right even as the Democrats
claim that they want to move far to the
left the ones who are actually winning
are the ones who are more moderate so
Rahm Emanuel who is the mayor of Chicago
R I mean this is he was he was Obama's
chief of staff this is not a person who
is a moderate Rahm Emanuel is warning
the Democrats guys you are you are way
off the rails here has a piece in The
Washington Post today called if they're
not true to their history Democrats wisk
squandering a rare opportunity
he says credit where credit is due
senators Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders have done a masterful job
baiting the rest of the field into
fighting this campaign on their turf
many voters inevitably presume today
that redistribution of wealth is the
Democratic Party's animating creed but
that's simply not true to history since
the New Deal Democrats have thrived when
championing ideas more in the belief
that rights come with responsibilities
and benefits are earned through work
which actually sounds a lot more like a
Republican Creed than a democratic Creed
he says we failed to return to that
agenda ahead of the 2020 election we
risk squandering a rare opportunity
fortunately we now have a chance to
shift that narrative
he says amid all the talk about programs
designed to redistribute America's
wealth the phrase most glaringly absent
from the 20/20 campaign to this point is
inclusive growth with former
Massachusetts governor Deval Patrick
entering the race last week and former
New York Mayor Michael Bloomberg
emerging as another late entrant we can
begin to have an ideas primary and
earnest we're stronger as a party when
we debate substantive proposals for how
to expand a prosperity and opportunity
but to meet the far-left big ideas
traditional liberals need to show up
with bold ideas of their own Rahm
Emanuel says admittedly I've been
critical of those trying to steer the
Democratic Party further to the left I
think Medicare for all is a pipe dream
though I support efforts to expand
coverage and control costs and much as I
agree the concentrated power is a threat
to American prosperity I believe a
universal basic income runs counter to
America's deep-seated belief that people
should earn their living by working hard
and playing by the rules as power and
money have flowed away from the working
and middle classes a change driven as
much by technology and global as a
by a rigged system government has too
frequently turned the other cheek since
we have consensus on the nature of the
problem the question then is how to
level the playing field Rahm Emanuel
says traditional liberals need to begin
offering their own bold ideas for three
principal reasons the first and most
important centers on history Franklin
Roosevelt's New Deal john f kennedy's
new frontier bill clinton's new covenant
and Barack Obama's belief that quote
there's not a liberal in America and a
conservative America there's the United
States of America all appealed to voters
by tapping into the nation's firmly
established belief that people should
earn their prosperity through hard work
Social Security and Medicare on handouts
they're financed by what workers pay
through a payroll tax the GI Bill and
AmeriCorps both often but both offer
tuition assistance in return for
national services Rahm Emanuel the
Earned Income Tax Credit is designed to
boost families working their way out of
poverty and then he talks about the fact
that when they win elections it's
because they have moved along the lines
of work deserves better pay not alone
lines of tearing down wealth he says
when our party has nominated candidates
banging the drum for redistribution like
George McGovern and Walter Mondale we've
lost hopefully bids from Bloomberg and
Patrick will serve as a wake-up call and
then he points out that these policies
are also bound to fail he says big ideas
aren't necessarily good and that is a
slap at Warren and Sanders he says with
any luck Bloomberg and Patrick will
support traditional liberals to
reanimate the bull' Democratic creed
centered on work responsibility shared
prosperity and equal access to
opportunity if the new contenders
inspire a new wave of progressive
thinking will not only prevail next
November but for years to come but will
those ideas prevail will those ideas
prevail because the Democratic Party is
fringing itself I mean that's that is
what is happening in real time the
Democratic Party is fringing itself and
in a second I will show you how the
Democratic Party is taking victories and
turning them into defeats because of
their own allegiance to radical ideas
I'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
there's a good shot dude that if you
have hair loss in your family you will
lose your hair as well two out of three
Jews will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they are 35
which is bad news for me I'm 35 the good
news with today's advancements in
science keeps offers proven treatments
that can combat the symptoms of hair
loss and help you keep the hair you have
at half the cost of your local pharmacy
and here's the thing once you start
losing significant amounts of hair
usually it ain't coming back so you
really should work
to stop the hair loss right now you
don't have to go broke to avoid going
bald keeps offers generic versions of
the only two fda-approved hair loss
products out there some you may have
tried them before you've probably never
done so for this price plus keeps now
offers a prescription shampoo to keep
your scalp healthy as well prevention is
key and keeps treatments really do work
that up to 90% effective at reducing and
stopping further hair loss so the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you're gonna say it so act fast find out
why keeps has more five-star reviews
than any of its competitors and nearly
100,000 men trust keeps for their hair
loss prevention medication the treatment
starts just 10 bucks a month plus for a
limited time you get your first month
for free if you're ready to take action
go to keeps calm slash bet and receive
your first month of treatment for free
that is ke e PS comm slash Ben keeps
calm / pen if you don't do this in five
years again a look around your bald
domes can be reflecting the mirror
you're gonna regret that you didn't call
up keeps go check them out right now it
keeps calm / Ben ke EPS calm / Ben okay
so as I say the Democratic Party despite
the advice of Barack Obama and Romney
annual that are moving in radical
directions according to the New York
Times the Democratic attorneys at
general group has now decided that they
will not endorse any candidate for a
state attorney general across the
country unless they explicitly endorse
abortion on demand which is full-scale
insanity the fact is that if Democrats
want to win in purple areas what they
shouldn't do is embrace their more
radical side but that is what they are
doing according to the New York Times an
association of Democratic state
attorneys general will become the first
National Party committee to impose an
explicit abortion litmus test on its
candidates announcing on Monday that it
will refuse to endorse anyone who does
not support reproductive rights and
expanding access to abortion services to
win financial and strategic backing from
the group candidates will be required to
make a public statement declaring their
support of abortion rights so it's an
actual full-on litmus test the group the
Democratic Attorneys General Association
recruits candidates and hopes their
campaigns with financial support data
analysis messaging and policy positions
the decision comes this series of state
legislatures have approved restrictive
laws designed to provoke a renewed legal
battle over abortion rights with the aim
to reach the US Supreme Court and topple
rule versus wade Letitia James the New
York AG who by the way is an awful AG I
pointed out when she was elected that
she said that she was going after Trump
which by the way is not the way
are supposed to work it's not I identify
the person I wish to target and then I
and then I find a crime its I've
identify a crime and then I go after the
criminal but she says attorneys general
are on the front lines you're the fight
for reproductive freedom they have the
power to protect your rights it is
important to note here that the same
Democratic Party that claims that
Attorney General William bar is a
political hack is openly calling for
attorneys general to be political hacks
because we have actually seen attorneys
general like Kamala Harris across the
country simply refused to defend the
laws of their states and the insane
Supreme Court has decided that if a
state attorney general refuses to defend
the law of a state the state no longer
has standing to sue for the law being
upheld this actually happened in the
Proposition 8 case in California where
the Californian public voted
overwhelmingly to protect traditional
marriage in the state constitution that
was that was elevated to the Supreme
Court
senator Cano and Senator Komal Harris
was then Attorney General of the state
of California she refused to defend
proposition 8 in court saying that she
could not in good conscience do so but
she also wouldn't resign right she just
wouldn't defend it and then the Ninth
Circuit said well since your state AG is
not defending the law the state of
California does not have the standing to
sue for the defense of its law in court
which is fully insane I mean it
basically gives veto power on any law to
a state AG I mean that's that's the
height of illegality the Democrats treat
the law as as a as a standard to be
tossed or adhered to at political whim
well now as I say the Democrats AG group
they're saying to their own people we're
not gonna back you unless you back
abortion on demand the new standard is
unlikely to have an immediate impact on
incumbents according to the New York
Times of 27 Democrat AG's currently in
office just one Jim hood of Mississippi
describes himself as a pro-life democrat
but officials believe it could have a
ripple effect throughout the Democratic
ecosystem reflecting the changing mores
of a national party that has moved
sharply to the left in the trump era and
embraced a set of purity tests on
divisive social issues Attorney General
Ellen Rosenblum
of Oregon she said state attorney
generals are now on the map is taking
the lead when it comes to democratic
values which should scare the hell out
of anybody I thought the AG's job was to
enforce the law not to enforce
Democratic priorities that are not the
law she says we're gonna be the ones
right out in front
hopefully other committees will follow
right along then new litmus test does
worry
Democrats who fear it could hurt their
party in rural areas and more moderate
suburban districts than ones Democrats
control of the house last fall there are
40 districts the Democrats one that were
in very close toss-up Trump or very
slightly Hillary districts in the last
election cycle former senator heidi
heitkamp of north dakota who served two
terms as her state AG described the
decision is wrongheaded she lost her
seat representing her red state after
voting against the confirmation of
justice Brett Kavanaugh last year and
she points out correctly the governor
John bel Edwards of Louisiana
just won re-election on Saturday after
campaigning on his opposition to
abortion and supporting a state law
barring abortion after the posting of
what becomes the fetuses heart can be
detected in other words in Louisiana if
you want to be a democratic gets elected
then probably you shouldn't be radically
pro-choice the Democrats are embracing
the politics of aoc in the land of
Donald Trump which makes no sense at all
politically speaking Heidi Heitkamp says
there are very principled people who are
Democrats who feel very strongly about
this issue for religious reasons and
when you say you're not welcome in our
party I think it's exclusionary you have
to look at the totality of the candidate
by the way even the way that Heitkamp
describes that is incorrect there are
many people I would say the vast
majority of people who are pro-life who
are not pro-life for religious reasons
they're not pro-life because of the book
of Psalms
they are pro-life because the science
suggests that human life begins at
conception in any case the Democratic
Attorney General Association is is now
forcing this litmus test down the
throats of their own people which is
full-scale political insanity especially
again given what just happened in
Louisiana as Charles Camozzi writes over
at first thing's Democrat John bel
Edwards dramatically expanded Medicaid
in the state yes but he also signed a
bill banning abortion after a heart beat
can be detected that's why he managed to
win the governorship of a deep red state
in which the president has a +12
approval rating as Camozzi points out
simply put bel Edwards never could have
won in such a state if you were not
pro-life his traditional valleys in this
area reflect both his deep commitment to
Catholicism and the views of Louisiana
voters especially Democratic voters of
color in the run-up to the election both
racial justice activist organizations
and Edwards his campaign itself made a
dramatic increase in african-american
voter turnout a major priority and with
good results voters of colors put
Edwards over the top especially when it
came to early vote
it would be interesting to notice
Eskimos see what white progressive
highly educated Democrats think of all
this after all they've been primarily
responsible for the party's turns the
kind of abortion extremism
that would have doomed an Orthodox
Democrat in a race like this one Mother
Jones ran a piece a few days before the
election with the headline is there
still room for an anti-abortion
hardliner in the Democratic Party the
answer in the party platform which
claims that abortion should be
unrestricted that it should be paid for
by pro lifers tax dollars and that it is
core to women's men's and young people's
health and well-being is obviously in
the negative now Democrats will support
bel Edwards when it comes to defeating
Donald Trump but the fact is that
Democrats who violate these sort of
radical left have become the enemy
inside the Democratic Party which is a
very bad move for them I mean the fact
is that Tulsi Gabbard has suggested that
abortion ought to be safe legal and rare
and she gets blasted by the people in
her own party I mean Democrats it's
foolishness I mean it's real foolishness
and you are starting to see this
breakout into the Democratic primary as
the more moderate candidates are ripped
up and down for the great sin of not
being radically to the left and as the
more leftist candidates signified to the
voters that they are more pure now will
primary voters buy it I'm not so sure
I'm not so sure we'll get to more of
this in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that in a time of great
casts you sometimes are going to need to
invest some of your money in a
diversified asset that is not subject to
the whims of centralized governments
yeah well the problem is that if you're
investing in currencies the fact is that
governments can manipulate the currency
and the value of your investment then
goes up and down with the value of the
of the Chinese government's or the
American government so for example last
week China devalued its currency and the
markets tanked one consequence is that
Bitcoin prices rose why because bitcoin
is basically digital gold effectively
what bitcoin is is it is a an asset that
you invest in and it is not as though
you receive a piece of gold mail or
something instead what it is it's a
digital asset whose value is assigned by
the market itself and there's blockchain
which prevents anybody from hacking it
or inflating the currency and you're not
gonna see a centralized government that
is inflating the currency in order to
pay off its debts or anything it is you
investing in a currency that is not
manipulable by central governments which
is why central governments have had such
a problem with Bitcoin which
one of the reasons you might think about
investing in Bitcoin well if you're
interested then you should think about
investing with eToro it's smart crypto
trading made easy eToro social trading
platform has over 11 million traders and
facilitates over 1 trillion bucks in
trading volume per year globally you can
access the world's best crypto
currencies they've got 15 different
coins available you can try before you
trade with a virtual portfolio with
$100,000 budget never miss a trading
trend with charts and pricing alert sign
up today at eToro comm Schapiro that's
Ichi Oro comm slash apparel eToro comm /
apparel give my tribe and they have that
ability to test out your investment
expertise before you put any arrow money
and check them out of each row comm
slash Schapiro so as I say the the gap
between these so-called moderates and
the radical leftist in the Democratic
Party is now breaking out into the open
so basically on the one side you have
Joe Biden people who to judge and maybe
Cory Booker and on the other side you
have people like Julian Castro Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren and the
Democrats seem fairly split almost right
down the middle on this particular issue
the reason that Joe Biden continues to
be durable in the polls the reason that
he has never budged below around 25 to
30 percent in the national polling data
is because people in the Democratic
Party understands I think a large chunk
of them understand that you push too far
to the left and the American people are
not up for this Joe Biden's case is
basically I'm the only one who can beat
Trump here is Joe Biden making that case
yesterday we're talking about this is
going to be this a cakewalk he is is
gonna have a billion dollars he's gonna
have an awful lot of the same kind of
negative campaigns and he's run in the
past and he is he's not going to be that
easy to beat so we better be careful
about who we nominate as our candidate
because the risk of nominating someone
who can't beat Donald Trump for doesn't
beat Donald Trump is a nation in a world
we don't want to leave to our kids
okay and so Biden's case is the only
person who can be Trump is somebody
who's not gonna be a full-scale crazy
the problem is the full scale crazies in
the Democratic Party are in control of
the boat at least when it comes to
social media and many of the Democrats
have followed them down this rat hole
this is why you end up with the
spectacle this morning of tea party
trending on Twitter so Tea Party was
turning on Twitter now is thing to
myself well the Tea Party hasn't really
in tournaments been mentioned for
several years I mean the tea party
basically went defunct as in terms of
having events as of like 2014-2015 like
it it just kind of stopped being a thing
so why exactly was it raining well it
turns out it was trending because way
back in 2011 peabody judge spoke at a
tea party event MP bootie judge said hey
guys i'm also interested in cutting the
links between Wall Street and big
government right which is a perfectly
plausible thing to say here's people who
judge talking to the tea party in new on
earth video okay so that was Buddha
judge when he was running for mayor of
South Bend actually trying to appeal to
people across the aisle by saying I'm
not going to castigate tea partiers his
terrorist he's getting blasted for this
today I mean just ripped up and down by
the entire Democratic Left how could he
have ever treated people in the Tea
Party as human beings you saw the same
thing with Joe Biden when Joe Biden said
yeah I used to work across the aisle
with my good friends like John McCain
and people how dare you work with John
McCain he was a very bad man that side
of the Democratic Party which side is
gonna win honestly for the good of the
country so it's kind of funny as a
conservative as a Republican Donald
Trump has a better shot of winning if he
runs against somebody like Elizabeth
Warren or Bernie Sanders then somebody
like Biden or bootie judge because the
more the more sort of moderate the
Democrats are the better shot they have
at winning so on the one hand as a
conservative I'm rooting for the
Democrats to nominate somebody like
Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren
because I don't think that they will I
don't think that they will survive the
election I think that they will implode
on impact but at the same time for the
good of the country I think it'd be much
better if the Democratic Party or a
reasonable party I think that having two
parties that are reasonable is a lot
better than having one that is
reasonable and one that is unreasonable
at least in terms of policy so on the
one hand I'm rooting for the Democrats
UNAM
the worst candidate which would be
somebody like Sanders are worn on the
other hand I'm rooting for the Democrats
to nominate somebody who actually
signifies that the country has a shot of
coming back together because the more
radical Democrats get the worse it is
for the country so again this whole
thing is breaking out in the open who
Lee and Castro who's been campaigning as
sort of bait o light right say he's run
to the radical left also he's slamming
Budi judge going well what does he
actually done what have you actually
done like seriously or Secretary of
Housing and Urban Development Housing
and Urban Development while I was a real
important gig over there
here's who Lee and Castro going after
booty judge I was mayor of a city that
was 14 times larger than South Bend
Indiana so I've seen a lot when it comes
to urban policy and not only that had a
stronger track record not only with the
black community in San Antonio versus
Mayor Buddha jazz is record with the
black community in South Bend I actually
have a record of accomplishment of
things that I can point to from the time
that I was mayor and HUD secretary
unlike Mayor Buddha says that you never
hear what did he actually do in office
when he was there Wow he was mayor of
San Antonio huge huge amazing and he's
not wrong that booty judge doesn't have
tons of experience but the fact is what
hooligan cast was really ticked it out
is the fact that Buddha judges getting
attention when hooli in Castro is
getting none meanwhile Cory Booker is
going after Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders as well he should he has a piece
in The New York Times today called stop
being dogmatic about public charter
schools says we can't dismiss good ideas
because they don't fit into neat
ideological boxes or don't personally
affect some of the louder more
privileged voices in the party which is
him saying to Elizabeth Warren you are
very wealthy you are very wealthy and
now you don't care about charter schools
which is weird because he used to
support them
here's cory booker blasting elizabeth
warren he says about 15 years ago when I
was living in brick towers now high-rise
at low income a housing community in
Newark Central Ward a neighbors stopped
me and told me about how her public her
child's public school was failing at
students like many others in our area at
the time desperate she asked if I knew a
way to help get her child into a private
school she knew as all parents do that a
great education was her child's primary
pathway to a better life and he talks
about how his parents got him into a
better school his parents in struggling
commune
across the country are going to
extraordinary lengths to try to get
their children into great public schools
there's even a trend of children's
Guardians using fake addresses to enroll
them in better schools in nearby
neighborhoods or towns living in fear of
hired investigators who follow children
home to verify their addresses
he says it's largely up to Democrats he
rips on Republicans and says for some
reason the Republicans are making the
problem worse which of course is untrue
but Booker's are Democrats of course
he's gonna lie about that he says it's
up to Democrats especially those of us
in this presidential primary race to
have a better discussion about practical
K through 12 solutions to ensure that
every child in our country can go to a
great public school that discussion
needs to include high achieving public
charter schools when local communities
call for them he says many public
charter schools have proven to be an
effective targeted tool to give children
with few other options a chance to
succeed and he points out that when he
was mayor of Newark they invested in
both traditional public schools and
high-performing public charter schools
and the citywide graduation rate rose to
77 percent in 2018 from 50 percent a
decade ago today he says Newark is
ranked the number one city in America
for beat the odds high poverty high
performance schools by the Center on
reinventing public education this is by
the way the one good thing that Cory
Booker did as mayor of Newark it is the
one interesting thing and the fact that
he has waited until now to run on it is
pretty amazing and demonstrative of just
how far the Democratic Party fell down
the rat hole here because the fact is
that if Booker had campaigned from the
outset on charter schools he'd be doing
much better in these primaries he really
would because again his record as mayor
of Newark was much more suggested of a
sort of Biden Nest bipartisanship than
it was of Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth
Warren now in a second we're gonna get
to Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
but suffice it to say that these sort of
subtweeting
of Sanders and Warren is now an ongoing
thing it's an ongoing thing and it
should be an ongoing thing inside the
Democratic Party I think it's a good
thing for the country that it's an
ongoing thing for the Democratic Party
we'll get to more of the war inside the
Democratic Party should they move
moderate or should they skew to the
radical left in just one second first
let's talk about saving you time and
money during the holiday season so
you're gonna be sending lots of gifts we
all know this and when you do this this
means you have to take all that stuff
you got a schlep it over to the post
office
you got to slap some stamps on it you
gotta wait in line listen Post Office is
great they're great services but why not
do all that stuff from home and not
schlep all the stuff in the car instead
use stamps calm
stamps.com brings all the services of
the US Postal Service direct to your
computer well
a small office sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages today
Sam's comm can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it is indeed
that simple with stamps commie at five
cents off every first class stamp up to
40% off Priority Mail so what the heck
are you waiting for
we use stamps come here at the Daily
wire offices I use it at home as well
you should so it's very easy they make
it very simple don't spend a minute of
your holiday season at the post office
this year sign up for stamps comm
instead no risk with my promo code
Shapiro and get that special offer to
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and the digital scale which is a
heck of an offer no long-term
commitments or contracts using that code
you'll be saving money and supporting
the show as well go to stamps comm click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro that stamps.com
pens her code Shapiro stamps comm never
go to the post office again okay in just
one second we'll get to the rest of the
Democratic breakdown Sanders and Warren
continuing too skewed to the left Warren
yeah she was running as the person with
one foot in in either camp and sort of
the moderate camp in the radical camp
not anymore
both feet are in the radical camp and in
honor of the hilarious cell phone by
Elizabeth Warren tweeting that she is
selling billionaire tears mugs on a
website that actually benefits the
billionaire we now have a brand new
offer for you we do our brand new offer
is that if you go over to Daley wire.com
right now what you will receive is a
special 20% off on our all-access
especial 20% off I mean that is a great
offer
and insider plus subscriptions when you
use the promo code more in tears because
obviously this doesn't when we say that
this this tumbler right here is gonna
fill with leftist tears
those are Elizabeth Warren's very salty
tears plus with insider plus and all
access you get the incredible leftist
Cheers hot or cold tumbler which is the
original the best not billionaire tears
first of all there's not that many
billionaires even if you get their tears
is it really going to replenish you left
its tears however I replenishing each
and every day today is the last day to
join so again that is promo called war
in tears for 20% off on your
subscription
come join the fun over at daily wire.com
where the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
all righty so Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren continue meanwhile to
skew to the left there's an article in
The Wall Street Journal talking about
Bernie Sanders his brokerage tax so the
fact is that Bernie Sanders he has a
proposal for a financial transaction tax
it is going to dramatically lower your
ability to invest in the market in fact
European countries that have tried to
levy a 50-point basis tax on all equity
trades they've had to dismantle that tax
because it's so bad for the markets
Sweden repealed it because all of their
trading volume I grated to London we
tried the the this sort of tax in 1914
but it was scrapped in 1965 because it
was producing little revenue and
lowering growth and according to
Georgetown economist James angle the tax
could reduce retirement savings by as
much as eight point five percent over a
typical workers lifetime but Bernie
Sanders is pushing it anyway which is
exactly what you would suspect meanwhile
Elizabeth Warren continues to be a
massive hypocrite so while she is
ripping on rich people she is worth
twelve million dollars it turns out that
her close allies who are very very rich
are maintaining campaign titles as
Warren's finance co-chairs this would be
Paul eager Minh and activist Shanti Frei
politico.com reporting that even as
Warren has sheered links to the
Democratic donor class fryin eager men
are courting big donors in the northeast
by organizing trips hosting events and
acting as conduits for information about
the campaign she's going to raise money
you know she will for for outside
sources to spend money also the DNC can
spend as much money as it wants and just
because her campaign force whereas big
donors does not mean the big donors
can't go over to the DNC which then
spends on behalf of Elizabeth Warren of
course it's all a scam Politico is
noting this they say their efforts
highlight how some wealthy donors
especially progressives in her
boston-based have continued to embrace
Warren and they are planning on giving
her a wat a lot of money apparently
these two these two very very rich
people eager Minh and Frey continue to
fly around the country trying to raise
money for her Steve Grossman former
chairman of the DNC says they're playing
a non-traditional role he says they are
rolling up their sleeves and they're
doing it he says that doesn't mean
they're not asking people for
substantial contributions Grossman said
adding that his wife Barbara donated
2,800 bucks to Warren after request
from fry Lorenz campaigns decline to
answer questions from political about
whether the campaign had paid for any
travel for even winner fry or for the
donors on trips that the finance
co-chairs have organized to early voting
States and other Warne events so again
if Warren becomes the Democratic nominee
according to Politico friends and allies
expect eager Minh and frights who work
to corral donors to write big checks to
the DNC and hope Warren fundraise for
other campaigns and state parties all of
which the campaign has said she would do
in a general election so a lot of this
is hypocrisy now Warren and Sanders
penned a letter together just today to
underscore their socialist bona fide
he's ripping on private equity they did
so in the most dishonest possible way
which is not a great shock they're both
ripping into a study that just came out
from Ernst and Young released in
partnership with the American investment
council which is a trade group for the
private equity industry the report was
was prepared as a response to private
equity legislation pushed by Warren in
Sanders called the stop Wall Street
looting Act of 2019 which should tell
you everything you need to know about
the act the legislation is designed to
basically tax private equity and what
the report said is guys private equity
is supporting a lot of jobs in this
country because private equity does a
couple of things
some people think private equity is all
these sort of leveraged buyouts of
companies that are falling down on the
job and then selling off all of their
assets they think it's the movie Wall
Street in other words well that's not
really all the private equity is doing
private equity is giving loans to
startup companies private equity is
investing in companies that need
investment and yes private equity is
taking over unprofitable companies
cutting the fat and relaunch in those
companies or selling off the assets if
those companies are no longer able to
support the workers or compete in the
global industry but the idea that
without private equity there would be
more jobs rather than fewer jobs is
purely asinine yes private equity does
engage much Joseph Schumpeter called
creative destruction there's no question
the private equity will buy up a
business at a bargain-basement price and
then sell off the assets if the business
is no longer operating fully but that
does not mean that the business would
continue to operate at a loss forever it
would just declare bankruptcy and in
many cases wouldn't even be able to
restructure so this this report from
Ernst and Young in the American
investment council estimates that the US
private equity sector provides
employment and earnings for 8.8
workers earning 600 billion dollars in
wages and benefits because the private
equity sector is supporting all of these
people with their investments obviously
they say the average US private equity
sector worker earned approximately 71
thousand dollars in wages and benefits
in 2018
so Elissa this is really funny Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders are very upset
with this study they say well why are
you using the average salary I mean that
includes people who are in private
equity at Goldman Sachs and also the
line worker over at Sears so why are you
averaging out the salary I don't know
the same reason that you average out the
salaries of women and men and then
pretend that women earn less than men on
a per point basis okay the fact is that
if you want to make the case that there
is tremendous economic inequality in the
American economy that of course is true
but that does not change the fact that
if you are talking about generating more
jobs and better jobs that is going to
require investment from somewhere in the
government ain't doing it nor is the
government qualified to do it
Ernst & Young also points out that the
US private equity sector directly
generated 1.1 trillion dollars of value
added in the United States in 2018 value
added measures a sectors or industries
contribution to the production of final
goods and services produced in the US or
US gross domestic product the US private
equity sectors value added added
compromised a product comprised
approximately 5% of u.s. GDP in 2018 so
fairly significant obviously also the US
private equity sector generates tax
revenue through US private equity firms
and private equity backed companies and
its employees in 2018 according to this
report the US private equity sector paid
174 billion dollars of federal state and
local taxes but according it to
Elizabeth Warren all of the private
equity sector is very bad and basically
should be put out of business why
because they point out that some private
equity deals end with the closing of
business which of course is true but a
private equity weren't doing it you know
it happened to those businesses they
would go bankrupt obviously meaning the
the issue Elizabeth Warren as well as
illustrious economic names like Ayane
Presley and Bernie Sanders and Rasheeda
Talib right these people signed this 10
page letter talking about how terrible
private equity is and the letter makes
no sense but I mean the letter talks
about how if you compare companies that
are invested in by private equity with
companies that are not invested in by
private equity the companies that are
not in
in by private equity very often do
better yes because why do you think
private equity gets involved in a
business you think that they're going to
buy into a successful business why would
anybody sell the successful business
private equity gets involved very often
when a company is already failing okay
but again it's for the left in the
United States right now for the hard
left it is about punishing success and
punishing people who are perceived as
successful right this is why Elizabeth
Warren is selling billionaire tears mugs
that's why she perceives billionaires as
the ideological enemy I perceive the
hard left is the ideological enemy
that's why we sold leftist ears months
right not liberal tears leftist years
liberals are people who disagree with me
on economics disagreed me on social
policy leftist are people who want to
shut down debate by pretending the
mainstream conservatism is outside the
Overton Window as a very different thing
Elizabeth Warren perceives billionaires
themselves to be the enemy which is why
she is selling billionaire tears mugs it
is very obvious what she is doing
she's just mirroring the same policy as
Britain's Labour Party the socialist
Labour Party over there they've been
taking aim at quote unquote obscene
billionaires pledging radical
redistribution of wealth to cut the
power of the super-rich and they the
transnational radical left is on the
rise okay meanwhile in a major policy
shift that should be celebrated the
Trump administration has now announced
that the the Trump administration views
American policy on Israeli settlements
as Israeli settlements are not a
violation of international law now is
always absurd to suggest that Israeli
settlements are a violation of
international law Jews have been living
in this area for literally thousands of
years the the international community
had suggested it was violation of the
Fourth Geneva Convention for Jews to
settle in these particular areas why
because there's a provision in the
Fourth Geneva Convention that says that
you're not allowed to deport your
population into occupied areas but the
population isn't being deported into
occupied areas Israel one that territory
in a legitimate war with Jordan has
offered the territory back to Jordan by
the way Jordan has turned it down
there's never been a sovereign
Palestinian state in that area every
offer to create one has been rejected by
the Palestinians and Jews have lived in
this area for literally thousands of
years thousands of years so that is not
the deportation of a foreign population
into a foreign area under the Fourth
Geneva Convention that is a domestic
population that has been living there
continuously
for literally thousands of years so good
for the Trump administration Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo announced during a
press briefing on Monday according to
Ryan's Vedra at the Daily wire that the
Trump administration was reversing an
Obama era policy and now does not view
Israel's settlements in the West Bank as
violation of international law
he says the Trump administration is
reversing the Obama administration's
approach toward Israeli settlements u.s.
public statements on settlements
activities in the West Bank have been
inconsistent over decades which is true
he said in 1978 the Carter
Administration categorically concluded
that Israel's establishment of civilian
settlements was inconsistent with
international law however in 1981
President Reagan disagreed with that
conclusion and stated he didn't believe
the settlements were inherently illegal
which obviously is true if Jews settled
in East Jerusalem why should that be
illegal in any way Pompeyo said
subsequent administration's recognize
that unrestrained settlement activity
could be an obstacle to peace but they
wisely and prudently recognized that
dwelling on legal positions didn't
advance peace however in December 2016
at the end of the previous
administration secretary Kerry changed
decades of this careful bipartisan
approach by publicly reaffirming the
supposed illegality of settlements which
basically suggests that that the
Palestinians own Judea Samaria and the
Gaza Strip outright without any
negotiation which of course is not only
true it raises the prospects of
terrorism right it's not only a base lie
to suggest this is historic Palestinian
territory it also raises the prospects
of terrorism because now you are
claiming that any Jew living on that
territory is a violation of
international law so why shouldn't the
Palestinians ethnically cleanse the Jews
in this area
Pompeyo says I want to emphasize several
important considerations first we
recognize that as Israeli courts have
the legal conclusions related to
individual settlements must depend on
assessments of specific facts and
circumstances on the ground therefore
the US government is expressing no view
on the legal status of any individual
settlement
he says Israeli courts have confirmed
legality of certain settlement
activities and has concluded that others
cannot be legally sustained second we're
not addressing or prejudging the status
of the West Bank that's for Israelis and
Palestinians to negotiate international
law does not compel a particular outcome
or create any legal obstacle to a
negotiated resolution third says Pompeo
the conclusion that will no longer
recognizes railey settlements as per se
inconsistent with international law is
based on the unique facts history and
circumstances presented by the
established civilian settlements in the
West Bank our decision said it is not
or decide legal conclusions regarding
situations and any other part of the
world and finally calling for the
aesthetic calling the establishment of
civilian settlements can inconsistent
with international law has not worked it
has not advanced the cause of peace the
hard truth is there will never be a
judicial resolution to the conflict
which of course is true good for the
Trump administration for recognizing
baseline reality on the ground the Obama
administration was attempting to force
Israel to abandon these particular areas
to the tender mercies of terrorists by
the way by trying to claim a historic
Jewish living in these areas was somehow
forbidden by international law it was
always a garbage position good for the
Trump administration for traversing it
ok now finally to the latest unimpeached
main gate now I haven't talked about
impeachment gate so far because frankly
I don't think the testimony today
matters very much I think the only
testimony that is probably going to
matter is the testimony tomorrow of
Gordon Sunland who's the EU ambassador
nonetheless the media are playing up the
testimony of Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh
the reason they're playing up this
testimony is because VIN Minh shows well
on TV Alexandrov Inman national security
council official he's a Purple Heart
recipient he's testified today about his
alarm at president Trump's request that
Ukraine investigate his political
opponents but as I have been saying for
literally weeks here there were many
people on that call their perceptions of
the call are utterly irrelevant to the
question of whether a crime was
committed whether an impeachable high
crime or misdemeanor was committed right
they have a perception about the call
you know who else has a perception about
to call you I have a perception about
the call we all have a perception about
the call because it turns out we've all
seen the memo / transcript of the call
VIN man himself suggests that the
transcript is pretty good right it's not
a full transcript but it does signify
what exactly was talked about so why
exactly are the Democrats calling fenman
they're calling VIN min for the same
reason that they were calling Bill
Taylor for the same reason that they've
been calling other members murray
Ivanovitch because they're trying to
create the image of a trump
administration gone wild so this is more
of an electoral tactic than an
impeachment one they're basically trying
to make the case that Trump ought not be
President because he has bad judgment
now you can make that case but making
that case in the context of an
impeachment inquiry is pretty ridiculous
one year out from the election if you
want to make the case the Trump is unfit
for the presidency we have these things
called elections in the United States it
can make that case you're gonna get the
chance to you're making the case all
along but turning this into an
impeachment inquiry
on the basis of testimony from people
like VIN Minh makes no sense now if you
want to bring forward people who have
first-hand knowledge that Trump was
attempting to solicit a bribe from
Ukraine for example but this is why
someone's testimony tomorrow manners cuz
he actually talked to Trump that's one
thing but propping up all of these third
parties who had perceptions of the call
is utterly irrelevant so really this is
all about optics right we all know this
is about optics so VIN Minh is being
brought forward for a couple of reasons
one because he has a long storied
history as a patriotic American too
because some people on the right were
foolish enough to attack him which is an
idiotic proposition you could have just
said listen his perception is not a
great consequence to the question of
whether Trump committed a crime right
he's welcome to his perception he's an
American patriot you know we're not you
don't have to castigate him as a person
in order to disagree with his perception
of the circumstances but a lot of people
on the right were ripping into him and
personally suggesting it was all
politically motivated and all the rest
of this sort of stuff so VIN Minh in
turn has now taken up the baton of I'm a
victim okay that he is being victimized
by by people on the right and Democrats
are playing this to the help they did
the same thing with Murray Ivanovich on
on Friday ivanovitch who says that she
was wrongly fired as ambassador the case
can certainly be made that she was were
only fired as ambassador but that does
not not criminally fired just bad policy
as she proclaimed that she was greatly
intimidated by Donald Trump tweeting
about her which of course is silly well
now VIN Minh is he testified this
morning and in his testimony he did a
routine suggesting that he was in dire
danger significant risk now maybe that's
true as a person who's been the subject
of the subject of many death threats
over the course of my career I can say
it is uncomfortable but the Democrats
are obviously playing this sort of thing
up because what they are attempting to
suggest is that Trump is militarizing
the civilian population against
witnesses who don't like him so here is
Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh said telling
his father they came from the Soviet
Union while the Soviet Union was still
standing when he was a child saying dad
I'll be fine as I justify that you know
this is it's high drama but it has
nothing to do with engagement
I'm sitting here today in the US Capitol
talking to our elected professionals
talking to our elected professionals is
proof that you made the right decision
forty years ago to leave the Soviet
Union come here to the United States of
America in search of a better life for
our family do not worry I will be fine
for telling the truth thank you again
for your consideration I'll be happy to
answer your questions right so that last
line there is basically people are
threatening me the did the President of
the United States is threatening me and
I'm standing up here being brave now
listen can it be true is that sure but
is this optics of course this is this is
optics and VIN Minh was definitely
playing this hopper I mean during the
testimony at one point somebody called
him mr. bin Minh and he immediately
corrected them and said no Lieutenant
Colonel because again the Democrats the
media they've been playing this hole
they did the same thing with Bill Taylor
right you served in Vietnam and you are
an American Hero and as an American Hero
you don't like Trump that's that's a lot
of the game that's being played here has
been been doing a little bit of it mr.
Vinh Minh you testified in your
deposition that you did not know the
whistleblower ranking member exiled
Lieutenant Colonel Berman please I live
lieutenant-colonel Binh Minh you
testified in the deposition that you did
not know who the whistleblower was all
right I do not know okay so VIN Minh
then testified that he was concerned by
the phone call and he didn't think it
was proper to the man that a foreign
government investigate US citizens that
testimony was contradicted by Tim
Morrison who is another official who's
on the phone call who suggested that he
was not concerned that anything illegal
was discussed on the phone call and also
he disagreed with VIN mins
characterization of the conversation VIN
Minh suggested that the term Purisima
was used on the call Morrison says that
he doesn't remember that term being used
on the call even VIN Minh acknowledged
that from his conversations in Ukraine
he didn't get the impression that the
Ukrainians were feeling pressured by
President Trump particularly when you
testified that the president president
Trump's request for a favor from
President zalenski would be considered
as a demand to president Solinsky after
this call did you ever hear from any
Ukraine
either in the United States or Ukraine
about any pressure that they felt to do
these investigations that President
Trump demanded not that can recall okay
so you can't recall having any
conversations with the Ukrainians where
they were they were expressing to him
any consternation about what President
trumpet actually demands so that's
really a key to his testimony but the
Democrats are trying to make it that the
key to his testimony is his perception
of the phone call more broadly and
that's the story of today's testimony
all the people who will be testifying
today are basically going to testify as
to their impressions on all of this and
their impressions are basically not
particularly useful they're not
particularly useful and so VIN Minh
testified he said that one he told
lawmakers that vile character attacks
against public servants testifying the
impeachment inquiry were reprehensible
and urged Americans to be better than
the callo and cowardly attacks he was
wearing his army uniform and medals
while he did all of this obviously he
was basically subtweeting Trump in all
of that and again this is about the
optics of electioneering this has very
little to do with the actual charges at
hand the other people who are scheduled
to testify today our kurt volker the
former US special envoy to ukraine
Jennifer Williams an aide to Vice
President Mike Pence and former national
security council Russia expert Tim
Morrison according to prepared testimony
Jennifer Williams said that trumps phone
call was unusual because it involved a
discussion what appeared to be a
domestic political matter
Williams was then attacked by Trump on
Twitter just days before her public
appearance Trump went after her on
Sunday as never Trump er who should
quote work out a better presidential
attack and he has you know Trump
obviously he's going after a lot of
these witnesses it's bad optics it's
foolish of Trump because again this is
directed toward elections Volcker told
lawmakers in October he didn't know of
any effort by Trump to press Ukraine to
investigate Biden he said that Vice
President Biden was never a topic of
discussion but other people have tried
to claim that Volcker was one of the
people working out Ukrainian foreign
policy women and Volcker have clashed
over what occurred at previous meetings
so we'll see what Volker has to say
today the bottom line is that none of
these people have first-hand knowledge
of what exactly it is that Trump wanted
the only person who really does
presumably
sunland who's gonna testify tomorrow and
that's where all the big headlines are
gonna be already time for a quick thing
I like and then a quick thing that I
hate so things that I like today as I
say I've been on a Paul Johnson kick I
really enjoy his work his story and
we're a very fun short biography of
Mozart back in 2013 so if you're a fan
of Mozart's music then this does bust a
few key myths about Mozart among them
that Mozart was an irreligious
philanderer that is not true he was a
deeply religious guy also that Mozart
was deeply troubled not a lot of
evidence to that effect also that his
wife Constance was was actually a
terrible wife who was sort of frivolous
right the perception of her in I'm an
ass
that obviously is untrue as well she's
actually a pretty good wife she
experienced the tragedy of losing a
bunch of children very early on in their
life she was sick a lot of their
marriage but she was she ensured that
basically their finances were taken care
of the idea that Mozart was perennially
in debt and was thus panicked about
money that is not true
either the idea that he was tremendously
at odds with his dad is not true so
basically all of the myths that you see
in Amadeus which would by the way is one
of my favorite movies they're really not
true Mozart was a happy guy who composed
music great music his entire life was an
expert on a variety of instruments
really understood the instruments was
religious was not in fact an idiot
savant the way that he is made out to be
and Amadeus he's actually wit a
brilliant fellow if you read his letters
it's pretty obvious that he was a very
very intelligent person so it's it's
really good it's it's short I mean so if
you want to know kind of the key facts
about Mozart's life plus some great
discussion of his music check out Mozart
a life by Paul Johnson ok time for a
quick thing that I hate already so this
is exciting stuff more cancelling more
canceling is necessary so now the New
York Times is going after gap Paul
Gallen which is very exciting
so Paul Gallen last I checked has been
dead for like 150 years right I mean
Paul Paul Gallen died in 1903 aged 54
and it wasn't like people haven't known
that he was kind of a scumbag for a
really long time I mean he his personal
life was a shambles he treated people
horribly but I was not aware that we are
now going to be in the business of going
back into history and determining when
people did bad stuff and then canceling
them there's literal a piece in The New
York Times called
is it is it
time gal Gwyn got cancelled museums are
reassessing the legacy of an artist who
had sex with teenage girls and called
the Polynesian people
he painted savages okay so that's bad
stuff also is his art good okay I'm
highly irritated by this notion that we
can't separate the art from the artists
in terms of appreciating the art now it
may give you a better understanding of
their motivations when they were
painting to understand what they were
thinking but that does not change the
actual art it doesn't change the art
itself right if the art itself is good
then the art itself ought to be seen as
good it should not be based purely on
the sort of deconstructionist narrative
that people in the past did bad stuff
therefore we can't look at their art
anymore this is stupid
okay so according to the New York Times
is it time to stop looking at Gowan
altogether that's the startling question
visitors here on the audio guide as they
walk through the goblin portraits
exhibition at the National Gallery in
London the show which runs through
January 26th focuses on goblins
depictions of himself his friends and
fellow artists and of the children he
fathered and the young girls he lived
with in Tahiti
a standout portrait in the exhibition
his tamanna has many parents in pictures
Galan's teenage lover holding a fan the
artist repeatedly entered into sexual
relations with young girls marrying two
of them and fathering children reads the
wall text dagwon undoubtedly exploited
his position as a privileged Westerner
to make the most of sexual freedoms
available to him in other words he was a
douchebag but everybody knows he was a
douchebag so I mean I'm fine with
examining Paul Gowens life that's fine
and we should always understand
understand the dark sides of history but
this attempt to quote unquote cancel a
dude 120 years after his death is fairly
ridiculous is it not
can't we just appreciate the art for
what it is understand that it came from
a bad place that this is a bad man and
then also recognize that the art is
interesting and has something to say if
we are now gonna get into the business
of examining the sins of great or small
of any person who creates art there's
not gonna be a lot of art it turns out
that a huge number of artists were
horrible horrible people horrible people
as my friend Andrew Clavin likes to say
talent falls on the smart and the dumb
on the on the good and the evil alike
but according to the New York Times it's
time to cancel it gal goin born in Paris
the son of a radical journalist Goguen
spends his early years in Peru before
returning to France he took a pay
in his 20s while working as a
stockbroker a profession he would soon
give up along with his wife and
children's make artful time he set sail
for Tahiti in 1891 searching for the
exotic surroundings he had known as a
boy in Peru hagwon spent most of the 12
remaining years of his life in Tahiti
and on the French Polynesian island of
Hiva OA cohabiting with adolescent girls
fathering more children and producing
his best-known paintings in the
international museum world Galvin is a
box-office hit there been a half-dozen
exhibitions of his work in the last few
years alone including important shows in
Paris Chicago and San Francisco yet in
an age of heightened public sensitivity
to issues of gender race and colonialism
museums are having to reassess his
legacy a couple of decades ago an
exhibition on the same theme would have
been a great deal more about formal
innovation said Christopher Rhea Pell a
killed Koch curator of the National
Gallery show know everything must be
viewed in a much more nuanced context he
added oh so in other words it used to
focus on his art now it's gonna focus on
the fact that we don't like him anymore
and the fact like by the way for a long
time the left was very much in vogue
with Paul Gallen because Paul Gauguin
had abandoned his wife and kids and was
seen as a political radical so only now
are they beginning to realize oh you
mean that the political radicalism went
along with him mistreating young girls
and treating native peoples horribly he
said I don't think any longer it's
enough to say oh well that's the way
they did it back then you don't have to
say that in order to recognize that
maybe you should assess him in an
artistic level Rhea Pell described
Goguen is a very complicated person a
very driven person a very callous person
said he was disappointed that his
overwhelming urge to make art led him to
hurt or use so many people badly
the show is co-produced with the
National Gallery of Canada and Ottawa
open in Ottawa in late May 9 labels were
have changed to avoid culturally
insensitive language according to the
museum's press office in in Ottawa the
title head of a savage mask was shown
with an extended label explaining the
word savage and barbarian considered
offensive today reflect attitudes common
to Galan's time and place elsewhere his
relationship with a young Tahitian woman
was changed to his relationship with a
13 or 14 year old Tahitian girl by the
way those changes are fine I don't see
any real problem with being more
specific in your description of gal wood
but as far as quote-unquote canceling
him I don't know what that is supposed
to mean
to other museum professionals
re-examining the lives of past artists
from a 21st century perspective is risky
because it could lead to the
kind of great art the person I can
totally important loathe but the work is
work said Vincent ated Olli who is taped
moderns director when a stage a major
galvan exhibit in 2010 once an artist
creates something it doesn't belong to
the artist anymore it belongs to the
world
otherwise he caution we should stop
reading the anti-semitic author Luiz
Ferdinand Selene or shunned Cervantes
and Shakespeare if we found something
unsavory about them that that of course
is correct but because he was a bad guy
apparently we're now supposed to cancel
him dagwon you pissed me off begins to
new nudes on a Tahitian beach 1894 a
poem by a New Zealand poet and academic
Salina to see Tala Marsh you strip me
bare ask to turn me on my side Troma fan
in my face etc etc the anonymity of his
Tahitian portraits is another cause of
frustration in the 2009 photographic
series Dee and Dallas do gal Glen and
New Zealand born Simone artist Tyla vow
has cut out the faces and gallons
reproduction and inserted photos of her
own sister and friend Doug winds heart
is a problem if it continues to be used
to frame the Pacific in this timely semi
damaged past when there's actually so
much going on says Carol and Verico a
senior lecturer in art it's such a
lively and dynamic culture within the
indigenous context as well so again the
the the notion that we are going to
quote-unquote cancel people 120 years
after the death because they were bad
when they lived there's no limit there's
no limiting principle here it turns out
that by historic standards most people
were bad and it turns out 100 years most
people gonna think we're bad so if you
like what is being done with Paul Gowen
and by all means recognize that in a
hundred years will be done to you and
that is not to justify Gowans behavior
gallon was again for the war for the
fourth time a douchebag when he was
alive but the attempt to cancel artists
and say we can't show their exhibitions
anymore because they're very bad people
that is not going to end well for the
artistic community above all already
we'll be back here later today for two
additional hours otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Jessa all Vera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
Democratic congressman Eric's wall well
broadcasts hot air on MSNBC but not so
much hot air as Democratic Senator Chris
Murphy or House Speaker Nancy Pelosi we
will examine the shameless gas bagger II
of our leaders check it out on the
Michael Nolt show
you
[Music]